ربما الاوضاع في دير البلح ووسط قطاع غزه
وايضا في خانيونس جنوب القطاع تتشابه الى
حد كبير مع ما يجري في مدينه غزه وشمال
القطاع هذه
الاماكن تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه وايضا من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه نحن نتحدث عن مناطق بعينها
ربما تتكثف فيها الغارات الاسرائيليه وهي
الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه خانيونس جنوب قطاع
غزه حيث قصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاس يه
بعده غارات منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه سواء تلك
المنازل في احياء عبسان والقرار وخزاعه
وبن سيله او في تلك المناطق التي باتت
تكثف فيها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
غاراتها وهي في منطقه وسط مدينه خانيونس
الغارات تقترب اكثر فاكثر من المناطق
القريبه من وسط مدينه خانيونس قصفت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه والمدفعيه
هذه المناطق بعنف لكن المناطق ربما الاكثر
قربا الى مستشفى ناصر ومناطق تواجد
النازحين ربما الان هي لا تتعرض الى ذلك
القصف العنيف لكن القصف الاسرائيلي مستمر
ويستهدف في جله منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه ربما
في مدينه غزه كانت ربما اعنف الغارات تلك
التي استهدفت مكان يتواجد فيه نازحين
فلسطينيين وهي الشبان او مقر الشبان
المسيحيه في مدينه غزه لكن ايضا في شمال
القطاع قصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
كذلك عده منازل في بلده جباليه ومخ جباليه
ايضا في منطقه بنسه هيلا قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه عده منازل لكن مع
استمرار الانقطاع التام للانترنت
والاتصالات بكل تاكيد سيكون هناك نقص في
المعلومات طبيعه هذه المنازل لمن تتبع هذه
المنازل للعائلات الفلسطينيه واي من هذه
العائلات بكل تاكيد تكون المعلومات منقوصه
في ظل هذا القصف الاسرائيلي المتواصل
والمكثف على اكثر من منطقه في قطاع غزه
القصف بكل تاكيد يتركز على تلك المناطق
الشر الشرقيه وحتى ان سيارات الاسعاف منذ
عده اسابيع لم تستطع الوصول الى هذه
المناطق وبكل تاكيد هناك شهداء وجرحى على
الارض ما زالوا ملقون ولم تستطع سيارات
الاسعاف ولا طواقم الدفاع المدني الوصول
اليهم في ايضا وسط قطاع غزه نفذت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه منذ ساعات الصباح
غارات وجل هذه الغارات على منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه في وسط مخيم انو صيرات قصفت
الطائرات منزلا دمرته وسوته بال ارض ونقل
عدد من الاصابات الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
هنا في وسط القطاع في دير البلع قصفت ايضا
منزلا بالقرب من مدرسه المزرعه التابعه
للاونروا ونقل عدد من الشهداء والجرحى الى
هذا المستشفى وبالتالي الغارات
الاسرائيليه ما زالت مستمره ومتواصله في
خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه مربعا سكنيا دمرته وسوته بالارض
وما زال هناك العشرات من الشهداء تحت
الانقاض وبالتالي ما زالت طواقم الاسعاف
التي استطاع طاعه الوصول بادوات البسيطه
وامكانياتها المتواضعه انتشال بعض
الجثامين ونقلوا الى مستشفى ناصر اكثر من
20 شهيد نقلوا الى مستشفى ناصر اليوم كذلك
كان هناك غاره في وسط مدينه خان يونس على
منزل هو الاخر دمر وسوي بالارض وايضا نقلت
سيارات الاسعاف اكثر من شهيد وعدد من
الاصابات والجرحى لكن كل هؤلاء في جل
الغارات الاسرائيليه سيارات مدنيه تقل
العدد الاول من المصابين والشهداء ومن ثم
تقوم سيارات الاسعاف بالتعرف على مكان
القصف الاسرائيلي والذهاب والتوجه الى تلك
المناطق لا سما في ظل انقطاع الاتصالات
والانترنت لليوم الثاني على التوالي
الاتصالات والانترنت مقطوع عن قطاع غزه
وبالتالي لا يوجد اي اتصال مع العالم
الخارجي ولا يوجد اتصال حتى مع الجهات
المعنيه من اجل ارسال سيارات اسعاف وطواقم
دفاع مدني الى الاماكن التي تقصى شكرا لك
هشام زقوط من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح